cielito díaz ven de boca chicos en la
plaza de mercado de santa elena en cali
unos jóvenes del lugar le preguntan que
por qué tiene precios tan altos que
había tenido que recurrir a un corredor
humanitario han llegado alimentos pero
los compradores denuncian que los
precios se están triplicando algunos
vecinos antes de la subida de precios
aseguran que ya les costaba comer nos
estamos muriendo de hambre habemos
muchas familias que solamente comemos un
desayuno o un almuerzo
las colas de gasolineras son
kilométricas y en algunos casos se está
tomando la gasolina vecinos aseguran que
sí que hay combustible pero que no la
quieren vender la gasolina nos quede la
sen robando acá la gasolina no no la
quisieron seguir vendiendo los pozos que
estaban saqueando eso es porque nosotros
necesitamos movilizarnos ante esta
situación en vendedores piden que por
fin se llegue a una solución estamos mal
en el país no hay alimentos no hay
absolutamente nada lo que necesitamos es
que el gobierno trate
conciliar con nosotros los colombianos y
que todos se normalicen en colombia
otros vecinos aseguran que entienden la
protesta de los jóvenes
la juventud es como usted en su casa
venga él dijo que lo represado hasta el
crece y el cristo vio a pensar esto es
lo que pasará con esta juventud ya
crecieron un argumento recurrente en el
mercado donde la gente señala su dedo
más allá de los bloqueos llegando hasta
el propio gobierno